i have good news for croatia
in our view
croatia is ready to receive its first
payment from next generation eu
so as soon as member states give their
green light croatia will receive 700
million euros
indeed croatia has made swift progress
in implementing the reforms and
investments
of its national recovery plan
in particular croatia has already
supported 70 companies to switch to
renewable energy sources
and become more energy efficient
croatia has also adopted its national
program for the energy renovation of
buildings and took measures to improve
water and waste management
and on reforms croatia has adopted a
strategy to combat corruption
and introduced new legislation to
prevent conflict of interest
it has also taken important steps to
strengthen the labour market with nude
legislation on minimum wage
and took measures to enhance social
protection
i really commend you for that
and finally
let me mention the new national road
safety plan
which will have a very concrete impact
for all croatians by improving road
safety in the country
so the first payment is on its way
and more will come
croatia will receive up to
6.3 billion euros in grants over the
next years
and this makes croatia the biggest
recipient of grants from next generation
eu compared to the size of its economy
so congratulations croatia
and you can always count on the
commission to support you
in making your recovery plan a success